Borders is back and this time I went to Colombia.
This country of about 50 million people actually feels like a lot of different countries,
because the landscapes and the cultures are so different depending on where you go.
You can never cover all the stories in one
country,
but I was able to assemble upon some of the most interesting things that I think are happening in Colombia.
There is a crisis at this border and I went to go
see what's happening with the many
refugees that are coming from Venezuela
into Colombia
and how Colombia is handling it.
And then I went out into some of the
deepest jungle I'd ever been in
to explore Colombia's cocaine economy, which
is based entirely on this one leaf:
the coca plant.
Oh and I got to see some
hippos during my trip, which was kind of weird.
I also got to go up to the
beautiful city of Cartagena, up in the
northern part of Colombia, to look into a
subject that I've never looked into before:
music and dance.
So over the next few weeks, I'm going to start releasing these episodes,
as always on Vox's YouTube
channel and on our Facebook Watch page
I hope you like them, I hope you learn something new
and I hope you get to know Colombia on a whole new level.